[Music]
evening everyone welcome to the next
revolution i'm steve hilton this is the
home of positive populism pro worker pro
family pro community and especially pro
america
one of the american establishment's
favorite authors was philip roth who
died in 2018 in september 2005 he
released a novel called the plot against
america in which fdr loses the 1940
election to a republican who goes on to
sign a peace treaty with the nazis it's
in a long tradition of characterizing
authoritarianism and fascism as
something exclusively associated with
the right in politics for example cbs
news last year said fascism is defined
as a political movement that embraces
far-right nationalism
this trend massively accelerated in the
last few years as the media the
intellectual elites the democrats never
trumpers everyone in the establishment
lost their minds over trump you know the
script trump is an authoritarian he's
bringing fascism to america he's hitler
and anyone who supports him is a nazi
listen to some of the things they said
there's been a lot of rhetoric that's
including from these stories about
general milley about trump and trump's
policies being nazi-like i don't think
that's a stretch at all just like
vladimir putin or erdogan or she and
china he used the power of government
corruptly to go after
his perceived political opponents
but it wasn't trump promoting the kind
of racial segregation that nazis would
cheer it's the woke left pushing it
everywhere from elementary schools to
universities
it wasn't trump using the power of the
state to silence views he didn't like
it was the democrats and their big tech
donors interfering in the election
suppressing stories harmful to their
candidate it's not trump
using the power of the state to go after
political opponents that would be the
biden regime
jailing the people like marine
lieutenant colonels duchell are brave
enough to speak out against them
it wasn't trump who told the faa to ban
news organizations from filming the
evidence of policy failure
and then what we saw this week a true
turning point in how we understand the
nature of this biden regime
on monday biden's attorney general the
man sold to us as a moderate who would
stop the alleged politicization of the
justice department did something i never
thought i'd see in america it's not the
first time garland has mobilized the
justice system in pursuit of political
vendettas
he did it over georgia's voting reforms
and the texas abortion law whatever you
think of those policies there's no
constitutional or legal case for the
federal justice department to intervene
it's all about playing politics
but this week
garland crossed a line
he deployed the full power and authority
of the federal justice system and law
enforcement
behind the claim that this person
is a domestic terrorist
every month i come here and i hear the
same thing
social emotional health
if you truly mean that you would end the
mask requirement tonight
or that this person is a domestic
terrorist
did it become acceptable to be tolerant
only when someone expresses a view that
we agree with when did it become
appropriate to allow the school board
i don't know who you think you are
but it is not appropriate it is not
allowable to silence bully or dismiss
our views as parents
they're saying that this person is a
domestic terrorist that this person is a
domestic terrorist
and this person and this person all of
them
domestic terrorists
parents
american parents who love their children
and want nothing more than to see them
properly educated not improperly
indoctrinated who want nothing more than
for their children to see their friends
faces at school
domestic terrorists i know that phrase
was first used in a letter from the
school board association run by democrat
operatives by the way calling on the
biden regime to police parent protests
but merrick garland should have rejected
the demand out of hand if there are
problems with harassment or violence at
school board meetings that is obviously
a matter for local law enforcement and
to be clear all of us who believe in
parents absolute right and frankly their
responsibility to protest
totally condemn harassment and violence
and disgraceful scenes like some we've
seen recently
but merrick garland didn't reject that
offensive school board letter out of
hand he didn't make clear that these are
local matters instead he invoked the
specter of the fbi what is that other
than an endorsement of the domestic
terrorist smear and a threat to parents
intimidating them into silence
i've seen these tactics in communist
hungary the heavy-handed coercive power
of the state
used to keep the citizens in line my
parents escaped all that and now to see
it happening here
in america
it's beyond belief
this is not the behavior of a normal
administration we were told that trump
was the one undermining democratic norms
and civility biden would restore them
we must end this uncivil war
that pit's red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal
we can do this
if we open our souls
instead of hardening our hearts
if
we show a little tolerance and humility
tolerance
is there anything more destructive
of political norms and the functioning
of civil political discourse than to
call your opponents domestic terrorists
it's been in the works for a while
remember when pelosi called republicans
enemies of the state
but now they've just come right out with
it if you challenge our political views
we'll put the fbi on you because you're
a domestic terrorist anyone who
disagrees with us has to be a domestic
terrorist because we are the only true
defenders of what is good and right and
noble and decent this is how they think
you know that if you've ever talked to
them it's always been a bit like this
with the left when conservatives
disagree with the left we say they're
wrong
when they disagree with us they say
we're bad people that's been the way
ever since i've been involved in
politics but in the last few years it's
just gotten so much worse i don't know
what it is trump social media the
divisive hate-filled rhetoric on msnbc
and cnn riling them all up
whatever it is it's gone from arrogance
and self-righteousness to a moral
superiority that is truly frightening
genuinely chilling
because you know who else thinks like
this
actual fascists think like this
biden loves saying the big question
facing the world is the battle between
democracy and authoritarianism
this is a battle between
the utility of democracies in the 21st
century and autocracies there's a lot of
a lot of autocracies that are counting
on
them being able to move more rapidly and
successfully
in an ever complicated world than
democracies can
now finally the elites have openly
recognized the possibility that
authoritarianism is present on the left
as well as the right as a recent piece
in the lefty establishment bible the
atlantic laid out and then right on cue
to actually prove it liberal pundit
jonathan trait argued in a piece this
week
that the only way to save democracy is
to destroy it and replace it with a
one-party system because any resistance
to the march of the far left is not
consistent with democracy
so now
as we see what is happening right here
in america as we see the government
censoring speech it doesn't approve of
as we see the government exploiting
emergency powers to extend its control
over our lives as we see the
glorification and veneration of the
state and the casual dismissal of
individual citizens and their rights as
we see the normalization of racialized
rhetoric and policy and as we see this
week the mobilization of law enforcement
against political opponents
we inevitably come to the conclusion
that this regime the biden regime is a
fascist regime
fascist in its mindset fascist in its
prejudice
fascist in its state-sponsored
authoritarianism fascists in its daily
actions that equate truth and justice
with the interests of the ruling party
the biden regime is a fascist regime and
it's time we said so clearly
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else